joining us now is minister of state for
department digital culture media and
sport which is a bit of a mouthful isn't
it matthew warman let's call him that
instead should we good morning to you
just a thought on what happened at
notting hill to start with well it's
obviously a tragic event and to have
seen so many people out trying to have a
lovely time on a bank holiday weekend to
have ended in in this way for at least
one individual is obviously a tragedy
but as you see the police are making
some progress and i just concur with
their uh appeal to people if they've got
any information to get in touch okay
thank you um talk to us about the cost
of living crisis if you would obviously
we'll have more from notting hill
throughout the course of the programme
um we got the price cap figure didn't we
3549
pounds what we that was from afghan what
we didn't get is a plan from the
government
well i think what you've seen is a
significant amount of help already up to
1200 pounds and sometimes beyond for
people uh who need it most and uh this
will absolutely be at the top of the
next prime minister's in tray as well so
there's help there and there is i'm sure
going to be help to come you acknowledge
that much more needs to be done well i
think it's obvious that the package that
was put forward a few weeks ago was done
in slightly different circumstances and
i think that's why you've seen both
leadership candidates lay out uh to some
extent uh the fact that some more needs
to be done yes what are we waiting for
well it's right i think when we have a
prime minister due to be put in place uh
a new prime minister due to be put in
place uh on monday then it's going to be
for them to make uh the detailed uh
plans that people need to see i think
that's that's a fair and sensible
process why minister why is that
well i think that the prime minister
when he stood down acknowledged that he
wasn't still prime minister he is still
prime minister and that's why he and
nadine sahar we have been working on uh
what the options might be but i do think
it's only fair and reasonable that
someone who is going to take over in
less than a week's time uh has the right
to say this is how i think it's best to
take the country forward through what
are going to be immensely challenging
time the reason is i i make the point i
think i'm writing saying that you
support rishi sooner he's talked about
hundreds of pounds being made available
but you know what what does that
actually mean people who are watching
this morning who saw that that price cap
had gone up to more than three and a
half thousand pounds uh last friday are
wondering how they're going to keep
their kids warm this winter yeah and
you're absolutely right lots of people
i've had lots of constituents uh in
touch individually what are they just
those uh sorts of worries and what
they're saying is that they're worried
about the uncertainty of what winter is
going to look like and of course they've
seen those headlines about the new
cap i think for me the most important
thing is that we target those who need
it most we target the most vulnerable
that's what you saw in that package that
differentiates between
some people who have greater needs than
others but acknowledge that everybody
needs help so what constitutes the most
vulnerable well i think pensioners in
particular those on fixed incomes
obviously we need to think about that we
need to think about people who are
particularly reliant on benefits but the
fact is as we heard from the chancellor
not long ago this is something that is
going to affect people somewhat higher
up the income scale as well and that's
why
the principles of the package that was
announced before i think are the right
ones which are to focus the help on
those who need it most but also to
acknowledge that a degree of
universality is the right one so
middle-income families can expect
support as well well as i say that will
be a matter for the new prime minister
but middle-income families got some
support already when rishi soon act was
chancellor i would think that those
principles should be continued yeah just
looking at i mean what the french are
doing and what the spanish are doing
they've already come up with quite a lot
of support for for people who live in
those countries including um a four
percent uh freeze as far as the french
concern i think edf one of their um one
of their energy companies as you know
they're taking an 8.4 billion pound hit
spain's agreed to a prize cap as well
and tax cuts as well
we are just waiting until we see who the
next prime minister is well i think
you've already seen a windfall tax
you've already seen that significant
package of support i don't disagree with
you that there needs to be
more to come and that's why both
leadership candidates have been talking
about it to such an extent already and
it's why from the prime minister on
sunday you saw that article talking
about
what this government has been doing and
what more needs to happen as well under
his successes would you support a freeze
in the energy price cap
well i think it it partly depends on
what you mean by that but ultimately the
price of fuel can't go up any higher of
energy can't go up any higher than what
it is uh at the moment well it's been
set at 3549
which which is already a significant
rise which has been offset uh to some
extent by uh the package that rishi
sunak announced what i support is
something that really does as i say
target those people who are most
vulnerable who need it most but also
acknowledges that there are people who
are somewhat higher up that income scale
that are going to need genuine help so
i'm sorry did you say that you were
supporting a freezing energy project no
what as i say what i support is
something that a drill a lot of the
energy companies are of course aren't
they that's what the energy bosses are
well so i think this needs to be
something that tackles uh both the
energy supply and energy security
challenges that we've got and tackles
the problems that people have as
individuals paying their own bills there
are a number of different policy ways
you might try and get to that conclusion
and as i say it is right that the next
prime minister makes those decisions
perhaps if we'd had a prime minister
before now then we wouldn't still be
waiting for what
he or she is going to do
i don't make the rules on how long it's
taken to go through this contest but i
think uh personally i would have
preferred it had it taken somewhat less
time yes and i think uh when the party
considers what uh the rules might look
like going forward uh that will i
suspect be something that many people
will take an interest in but that's not
a problem that we can address right now
we've got less than a week until a new
prime minister is in place in fact yeah
next monday you quite right 5th of
september we should find out who that is
i suppose an easy way iran that would
have been for your man to have pulled
out before now well i think uh rishi is
still fighting absolutely for every vote
you're seeing him going out meeting huge
numbers of party members right even
up to this moment
and i think that this is if you're going
to have a contest it is sensible to have
a contest it was widely pointed out
before uh boris johnson stood down how
disruptive this process would be that is
deeply regrettable and it's not more
true now than ever
but i do think as i say less than a week
ago it is what it is right now um how
are you looking back on his reign
i think well for instance one of the
reasons why i'm out today is talking
about huge growth in broadband uh uh
that was my cube provision exactly
so i think there's lots of things i in
my own constituency we're getting a huge
new a e there are lots of things under
that leveling up agenda that boris
johnson i think will look back on and be
hugely proud of and that broadband
announcement uh today we've hit 70
gigabit capable uh premises uh today
that's up from nine percent in 2019
that's a huge shift in a very short
period and it comes from the focus that
number 10 delivered why can i never get
internet on the train then minister
internet coverage on railways is a
particular challenge some of it is down
to the design physically of railways we
have again made huge progress on that
and partly i've never noticed it well
partly we've put it into the contracts
of the trade at the train operating
companies in some cases which means that
it is a much more important part
of their delivery but i share your
frustration on many occasions exactly um
just a final thought let's send where we
started should we um tory voters um
support nationalizing energy firms at
least in the short term that according
to a yougov uh poll 47
almost half of jury voters that were
asked said that we should nationalize
the energy firms for now what do you
think
well i think the way that the market has
been regulated hasn't worked as well as
it could have done in the interests of
consumers i think that what we've got to
see is some improvement in a host of
issues for me i'm not sure whether
nationalization does anything other than
borrow a huge amount of money today in
order to buy companies that will then
have to pay back that borrowing through
taxation so for me it doesn't work but i
understand the frustration that is at
the back of that uh suggestion and i
think we need to address the concerns
that people have rather than necessarily
using that would you address those
concerns well as as i say it's partly
about uk energy security it's partly
about investing in nuclear for instance
you've got the chancellor over in the
u.s today talking about how we can make
sure that nuclear is a greater part of
our energy mix we've got to try and
tackle what is a long-standing problem
in a lot a lot of different ways okay
minister it's great to talk to you thank
you for joining us this morning really
appreciate it thank you